I can't believe you would do this to me
right wait where'd you find a story I
found it on all kpop.com don't judge me
so I can explain so so like what
happened so okay so what happened yeah
explained
this way Japanese housewife lost her
life savings to a man pretending to be a
K-pop Idol that's on you how do you do
that so he it's like reverse like he's
only can only fans and she's the simp
huh exactly well good for him it's about
time yeah it is it is Progressive
equality get yours bud so the housewife
spent her entire life savings
on this guy 5000.
2.5 million Japanese Yen 18 Grand
actually 18 Grand yeah that's her life
saving that's her life savings is she uh
you said housewife is she married or
single well let's get to that so so she
is age 44. she was deceived by a man
um who
he calls himself an underground Idol
underground huh so he that means they're
independently managed they perform small
venues and they're interacting closely
with fans kind of like the backyard
wrestling
right he pointed at us for the backyard
wrestling you guys like that [__]
no but like K-pop but Japanese pop
underground Idol culture is what it's
called it allows fans to meet closely
with their beloved artists build a
strong bond with them early almost like
what happened with Bart and uh what the
[__] is his name who was at the Super
Bowl Bruno Mars Bart knows Bruno Mars oh
yeah yeah yeah what no wait one of our
close friends
um kind of semi-discovered him and they
used to record all the time and Bart was
just there yeah so he would invite us to
be like I got this artist he's really
good so we would just go and watch
nobody shows that we would go to Bruno
shows and it was like not his show but
the the roster was like it was bad
because it's just he's just performing
it's like what remember Lady Gaga right
before she came up she used to do piano
bars and stuff like that like yeah just
like open mics and [__] underground [__]
yeah no no it was it was out here like
um it was like in King King in Hollywood
or it was just like spaces here but then
like it would just be like his family
and a handful of us just there
supporting you know like such a good
performer so in Japan there's about 10
000 of these underground Idols were
active and in the case of the male Idols
they're called menchika
does that I don't know
[Laughter]
um so yeah while living in Tokyo with
her husband and and her and her daughter
this household I fell in love with this
K-pop
um Idol during covid but she had to stay
at home more often but then when he
revealed his mask was she like oh that's
ugly yeah well probably bummed out
um so she receives a flyer for a
performance and she was excited to see
the words come see the performance by a
member who looks like a Korean Idol and
then she visited looks like this guy
named Shin okubu weekly and spent 294
dollars per visit on tickets she
competed with other women to spend what
they would they have this like session
with them right so it's like you could
spend 100 seconds with this Idol 100
seconds 100 seconds so she would spend
money every week to just go hang out
with this guy for 100 seconds this is a
thing over there I wonder if there's
like a dude with a timer and go
guarantees I'll take that job I'll be
that guy
this is the part that I was like this is
a reveal
turned out that this person was actually
a Japanese person who spoke Korean
fluently got gypped she couldn't tell
the difference huh so the moment she
found out the truth she felt dumb she
spent her savings but she'll take this
as a lesson
wait so she didn't get catfished not
catfish it was what she saw everything
she got to talk to the dude talked to
him but he's not Korean he's Japanese so
that's the only thing that's a deal
breaker he's Japanese that's the worst
thing to find out about something
[__] funny he's like I got Scandal I
guess I'll learn
the funny thing is she's Japanese yeah
let's do the math how many seconds she
spent with him and she's devastated that
he's Japanese not Korean she wanted a
K-pop Idol and she got a Japanese guy
who was LARPing as a K-pop Idol Oh my
God that's [__] hilarious who knows
Korean
wow that's [__] hilarious I can't
believe you would do this to me right
wait where'd you find a story I found it
on all kpop.com don't judge me
I can explain so so like what happened
so okay so what happened yeah explain it
yeah it's like my little brother
um he's like super into nerd culture
like anime stuff and he was like he sent
me this like link to like some anime
thing that I and then I found it that
because he's into it yeah yeah does it
happen yeah that happens yeah yeah I
don't like anime by the way did she did
she find out in front of him or did she
notice like that she was devastated like
no he's [__] Japanese it doesn't say
it just says that she found out the
truth and then she felt like a [__]
idiot what I don't understand is like
so she blows all this [__] money
right 294 a pop no nobody gives a [__]
it's crazy you think other people would
react like that
like the other fans or is that at least
one did so there's gonna be more damn
you're a dirty [__] Japanese
yeah seriously wow maybe because then if
you want like a real K-pop Star
it it feels like it feels like you got
the fake one if it's Japanese
Chinese or something it's a little
different there right you say Asia
because everyone's intermingling like a
sexyama is he Japanese is he Korean I
think he's what's called a design Ichi
which is Korean people born in
um Japan oh we're getting in he's born
in Japan what's that term again is it
still Korean so there's like hella it's
like Chinatown right like imagine if for
hella Generations Koreans were in Japan
yeah and they adopt Japanese names but
they marry other Koreans it's like that
it's like being Jewish in America you
Jewish people you're like whatever but
you have English names or whatever yeah
it's kind of like that so so there's
there's a lot of Koreans that can speak
Japanese with Japanese names so it's the
same [__] right yeah they all look the
same to me
but they give me one give me one of
those
guys
when you go don't do it Steve to a
Japanese restaurant right you go to it's
like and then you're like oh we're gonna
get some [__] sushi right yeah I put
down the water I go yeah you feel like
they're Japanese as [__] right and then
you look
and then you go wait a minute hold on
they're speaking Mandarin in the kitchen
oh yeah and then and then you look back
and then there's like Hector in the back
and you're like what the [__] yeah and
then do you feel like why am I paying
these prices it's not even real
do you ever feel like that because I
know you do erase the son of a [__]
yeah I do yeah hey Hector don't serve me
raw fish yeah unless it's Ceviche that's
delicious so I was on a trip with with
some friends right and uh we went to
this match of whites or what
no
mixed race okay so straight while I say
that so he has a very diverse group of
friends
um so yeah some of my friends from
Mexican right and so I went to some of
them now but but I went to go pick up
like Mexican food from the spot right
and we weren't in a place that
traditionally has Mexican food right so
when I brought the food back you know
one of my friends the Mexican
um opened up the food and then then he's
like oh this isn't this is white people
[__] Mexican food
and then I actually went to pick up the
food so I'm like oh like everyone there
was Mexican from the customers yeah
everyone like yeah like no like the
workers like you could see it all
through glass everybody was Mexican so
you could just say like it's not good
but like it was literally just Mexican
food Mexican people saying Panda Express
not Chinese but it's like the owner is
Chinese yeah it's Chinese as somebody
yeah so if you go it says Chinese As It
Gets in Hawaii right Panda Express why
are you asking me I'm not from there I
mean I'm telling you in a question okay
cause you don't have to take
account exactly you're telling me in a
question [__] can you do more of that
that part but yeah yeah classic and I
was just like no there's everyone's
Mexican and they just did he just didn't
know what to say after that he's just
like oh like whatever like [__]
Whopper eats very water that makes it
white people food they look at the rice
they're like no flavor that's like I saw
some video there's some videos like this
chick who takes she takes her Italian
husband to Buca di Beppo and it's like
yes I saw that what the [__] are you
even doing like other than just being a
pessimist yeah like why are you thinking
it's more a son of a [__] he's like
he's like from Italy [__] Italian I
don't know and then she's like he's like
weeping like a little Italian
grandmother like oh that boy wondering
if they do this too beautiful Italian
food and it's like you're booking a
[__] Beppo in Albuquerque New Mexico
what do you expect what do you [__]
sitting there doing are they do they all
look like mazes yeah
dude and you walk through the kitchen
they want you to accidentally go in the
back and wash some dishes I think so you
can't find your way back to the Sea it's
so big yeah I like how you you can pay
extra to sit in the kitchen but then
like you're under the Cleveland it's
like these lights and it's like really
oh yeah you can get a chef's table Chef
stable what does that mean you're just
eating in the kitchen you get to watch
them put it all in the microwave
[Laughter]
now the tomato sauce out of a can out of
a jar Hot Plate it's like yeah I just
seen you take it out yeah I know I
didn't know that yeah but the garlic
bread is banging bro do you think yeah
do you think the inverse happens in
other countries like let's say there's a
Johnny Rockets in like China and then
they go to the back and they don't see a
white person they get pissed
like what the [__] what's the vice versa
they're Chinese too yeah this is
authentic they're not fooling me
it's not real American
yeah I feel that too if you go to
Denny's in Japan they better be white oh
Denny's in Japan's really good it's
better it is it's way better you know
how Denny's out here is like what the
[__] why we gotta go to Daddy's right
over there it's like different I heard I
heard yoshinoa is good
and they don't give it to you in those
shitty ass like styrofoam bowls they
give it to you in a like porcelain bowls
oh [__] porcelain whoa good and they
crack an egg on top and all that [__]
it's good dude it's probably because
they don't have homeless guys chucking
their [__] silverware they still take
EBT
[__] I mean come on yeah that's why I
think that's why maybe I'm nuts that's
why I don't have porcelain out here
maybe it's crazy it's like controversial
opinion whatever this video is over